[Musik]
china in den sanddünen von dürnrohr
dieses naturerlebnis ist für mich
schlicht überwältigend samt feinster
sand so weit das auge reicht
[Applaus]
in unserem bisherigen folgen sind wir
von venedig über istanbul quer doch die
türkei doch der kaukasus nach
zentralasien und von kirgistan nach
china gereist
in einem chinesischen dorf bei code dann
haben wir eine ungarische seidenweber
familie der sucht und von dort sind wir
nun mit dem flugzeug unterwegs nach
dünger
[Musik]
irgendwo hier am rand dieser wüste muss
sie zu sehen sein
die module sind mit den weltberühmten
baugruppen in diesen sandsteinfelsen
haben ähnliche zwischen dem vierten und
zwölften jahrhundert etwa 1000 kavernen
geschlagen
[Musik]
diese gruppen gehören zu den wichtigsten
politischen kultur städten der welt
sie sind zeugen des austauschs der
religionen denn der buddhismus hat sich
seinerzeit von indien aus die
seidenstraße nach china verbreitet dies
ist jörg er ist ein bekannter
chinesischer kunstmaler und sohn des
verstorbenen nur grau grotten
konservator die grabstätte seines vaters
liegt direkt gegenüber dem eingang der
berühmten höhne
[Applaus]
jahrgang verehrt seinen vater von ihm
hat er auch einen ganz speziellen
auftrag erhalten
tja was soll in der nähe von logo die
familieneigene kraft weiter ausbauen
[Musik]
in china gehört es zur tradition dass
kinder die wünsche der eltern
respektieren und ihre eigenen
lebensziele hinter dieser wünsche
zurückstellen
tja huangs privat grotte liegt etwa 60
kilometer südlich von nokia huang hat
sein höhlen nachbar and vor 15 jahren
eröffnet durch einen langfristigen
pachtvertrag sollte es für die nächsten
jahrzehnte vor staatlichen eingriffen
geschützt sein
[Musik]
tja huang führt mich in einen raum mit
kopien von malereien mit wandbild und
die einst die berühmte motto
geschmückten und im letzten jahrhundert
von forschungen westliche museen
verschleppt worden sind hier wird butter
als großer leere dargestellt
[Musik]
die symbolisierten blumen im kuppel
gewölbe stellen das gute da in diesem
ersten raum hat jahrelang versucht den
auftrag seines verstorbenen vaters zu
erfüllen
geraubte motto kunst soll so wenigstens
in coupéform hier in seiner gruppe
wieder aufleben
im zugangsstollen zur nächsten grotte
können besucherinnen symbolisierten
blüten ihre namen eintragen und sich so
in der kwf ewigen tief unter der
erdoberfläche arbeiten zwei lokale
künstlerin anna broda darstellung sie
versuchen sich dabei präzise an eine
berühmte vorlage aus japan zu halten
bignone ist wegen der wüste eine hölle
für die menschen aber ein paradies für
künstler sagt mirja huang und für
umfasste die idee seiner familie nicht
nur den blick in die vergangenheit
sondern auch auf die gegenwart und in
die zukunft in bonn ist die kunst vor
600 jahren stehen geblieben
die vision meiner eltern war hier in
dieser neuen grotte nicht nur alte
verlorene meisterwerke zu rekonstruieren
sondern auch platz für zeitgenössische
künstler und neue kunst zu schaffen
dann wäre es eine privat krott der auch
künstlern aus aller welt als
experimentierfeld öffnen eine sensation
im zentristische gesteuerten
chinesischen kulturbetrieb
schüler mit denen er gearbeitet hat
haben diese darstellung auf papier
entworfen und chuang verewigt die sie
nun als wandbild
überraschend für einen chinesen hat sich
yang jetzt vom versprechen an seine
eltern emanzipierter will seine karte
nicht mehr nur als familienerbe
weiterführen
ich habe schon 15 jahre für die grotte
gearbeitet und somit mein versprechen
für meinen vater erfüllt ich habe das
feuer entfacht doch nun soll dieses
familienprojekt an ein team von jungen
leuten abgegeben werden
internationale künstler damit ich selbst
wieder meine eigenen bilder malen kann
in diesem raum erbgang seine verstorbene
mutter einst eine renommierte künstlerin
und zusammen mit seinem vater hüterin
der moral karten den letzten entwurf von
ihr die fliegenden bruders hat yahoo
draußen im flussbett dann die felswand
gemalt und ja auch die mutter habe ihm
ein spezielles motto mit auf den weg
gegeben
die auf nach immer weiter
denn kunst ist leben und leben ist kunst
auch im alltag
[Musik]
vielleicht wird das ja huang doch noch
gelingen seine private karte zu einem
anerkannten breiter abgestützten
kulturzentrum auszubauen
[Musik]
einst reisten die händler der
seitenstraße in die wüstenstadt heute
überrennen die touristen in wang ist
camille führer der ersten stunde
ende der 90er setzte er auf den
tourismus statt auf den acker da wen
bank kaufte sich damals zwei kamele
heute besitzt dafür
[Musik]
jeden morgen bringt es sie in aller
herrgottsfrüh raus um die touristen in
die geheimnisse der wüste einzuweihen
[Musik]
bin wann ist längst nicht mehr der
einzige dutzende verdienen heute ihr
geld als kamel führer und nicht mehr als
bauern noch im dunkeln geht es los zu
den berühmten singenden dünen von jin
wang zum einmaligen sonnenaufgang der
taklamakan wüste
[Applaus]
[Musik]
in wangs heimatstadt tino lang gehört zu
den top ten von chinas reisezielen
[Musik]
massentourismus gibt es in china noch
nicht lange
erst vor 20 jahren führte die regierung
offiziell bezahlt der urlaubstage 1
seither boomt der tourismus und die
oasenstadt an der seidenstraße kann sich
kaum mehr retten vor dem ansturm der
neuen chinesischen mittelklasse
bald schon flitzen auch
hochgeschwindigkeitszüge hierher in die
wüste die touristenzahlen sollen sich
dann noch einmal verdoppeln
[Musik]
kamel pionier bin wang hat den schritt
vom bauern zum kamel züchter nie bereut
er kann sich heute schon gar nicht mehr
vorstellen wie er ohne die touristen
überleben würde
das war überlebenswichtig denn die wüste
frist das farmland auf nur dank der
geschäfte mit den kamelen kann ich meine
familie heute die touristen suchen hier
nicht etwa die einsamkeit im gegenteil
was zählt ist das kollektive erlebnis
man wir spüren dass man nie alleine ist
als chinese wie fühlt sich dieses junge
paar hier inmitten von hunderten von
touristen ist sehr groß wir haben viele
verschiedene kulturen
wir sind hier um touristen aus allen
gegenden chinas zu treffen
wir verstehen uns untereinander sehr gut
das reisen trägt dazu bei dass wir auch
noch besser kennenlernen es ist mittag
bin wann macht sich auf den heimweg
er und seine tiere haben genug für heute
ich bin müde
ich habe heute morgen zwei runden
gemacht mit fünf gästen jede runde
bedeutet eineinhalb stunden marsch durch
die wüste
das ist harte arbeit
nach den wahlen sieht die wüste heute
nicht mehr als feind sondern schätzt sie
als einkommensquelle
ich begehe die dünen von den hang lieber
abseits vom aberwitzigen touristenrummel
und gedenke dabei der karawanen die
einst unter schwierigsten bedingungen in
dieser seitenstraßen region unterwegs
waren und viel zur entwicklung unserer
geschichte kultur und wirtschaft
beigetragen haben
hier aber wir sind nicht mit kamelen
sondern im klimatisierten auto unterwegs
vergleichsweise rar ist komfortabel
immer wieder begegnen wir riesigen
windenergieanlagen diesem niemandsland
wo nicht mehr kamele sondern modernste
sattelschlepper riesige warenmengen über
die neu asphaltierte seitenstraße kam
hier wird deutlich dass sich jener jetzt
auch den alternativ energien zuwenden
von jin wang sind wir auf der autobahn
nach chicago angereist jene stadt wo
einst die china reißenden der großen
mauer gegenüber standen
die tore der festung von jiegu an
markierten lange zeit den eintritt von
barbaren damit in die zivilisation ins
kaiserreich hinter der mauer ins innere
china wie es heute noch genannt wird
von der chinesischen mauer sind in
dieser region an den berg aus live vom
einige teilstücke erhalten geblieben
für mich ist es ein großes erlebnis
diesen abschnitt hochzugehen
die chinesische mauer gilt das weltweit
größtes bauwerk das jemals errichtet
worden
und nicht nur ich auch sie ist
offensichtlich hoch vergnügt wo liegen
christin aus peking sind spontan das
volkslied über die große mauer
hoho hahaha
warum sind sie hier auf der großen mauer
so fröhlich ein sprichwort sagt nur wer
die mauer besucht wird kraftvoll in
körper und geist jetzt bin ich auf der
mauer jetzt bin ich stark
[Musik]
kaum vorstellbar was geleistet werden
muss dem einst die mauer in einer
gesamtlänge von über 9000 kilometern zu
errichten
[Musik]
dieses power teilstück das im volksmund
auch als hängende mauer bezeichnet wird
ist von einem privaten chinesischen
unternehmer sorgfältig restauriert
worden
ich treffe yang yang für den betreiber
dieses mauerabschnitt seine geschichte
ist ein symbol für die chancen und
tücken der wirtschaftlichen öffnung
chinas
in der private initiative geschätzt aber
nicht immer honoriert werden
vor 15 jahren hat yang yang fu mit den
restaurierungsarbeiten begonnen
doch nun hat das kulturministerium
entschieden dass mauer anlagen nicht
mehr privat geführt werden dürfen
yang yang vor wird sein lebenswerk
wahrscheinlich bald dem staat übergeben
müssen und wohl nur einen teil von dem
geld zurückgehalten
dass er und sein projekt gesteckt hat er
ist enttäuscht gibt sich diplomatisch
ich habe schon ein paar millionen jahren
investiert für die restauration und die
pflanzen und bäume ich bereue nicht dass
ich das gemacht habe
auch wenn ich große schulden haben werde
wenn mich jetzt jemand unterstützt aus
volks liebe und liebe zu mauer werde ich
spenden akzeptieren unterkriegen lässt
sich jan jung für alter licht und
repariert mit seinem team ein stück der
mauer
die jetzige situation ist sehr schwierig
für yang hyung vor und wir möchten
wissen was er in 20 jahren wohl sagen
wäre wenn er mal auf sein lebenswerk
zurückblickt
[Musik]
ich kann dann vermutlich mindestens
sagen all die mühe hat sich gelohnt und
ich kann dann zu mir selbst sagen ein
bisschen bin ich ein großer mann und ich
bin sehr stolz auf mein lebenswerk yang
hyung fuhr ist nicht sicher über den
betrieb auf privater basis weiterführen
darf aber und das ist das wichtigste
er hat als bürger einen wichtigen teil
zum erhalt der mauer geleistet
[Musik]
das engagement von jung hat mich
beeindruckt besten perspektiven aber
stimmen nachdenklich
wir fahren weiter südostwärts von tiguan
her erreichen wir die stadt champion
[Musik]
eineinhalb millionen menschen wohnen in
dieser stadt schon marco polo soll hier
auf seiner reise verweigert haben
ein denkmal zeugt von marke buell wo
china erlebt in den letzten 20 jahren
die größte migrationswelle der
menschheitsgeschichte in der hoffnung
auf jobs in der industrie sind etwa 300
millionen menschen in die stadt gezogen
weggezogen von land wie zb den bezirk
sondern in der nähe von shanghai
[Musik]
die landwirtschaft auf 2300 metern höhe
trägt das karge leben der menschen von
chinas fortschritt spüren wir nichts
abgesehen von den stromleitungen hat es
hier schon zum auszeiten so ausgesehen
damals wurden hier noch die pferde der
roten armee gezüchtet bauer panzern ping
ist hier geboren seine eltern haben
während chinas kulturrevolution als
stall knechte auf der pferdefarm
geschuftet
[Musik]
wie jeden morgen wird höchst pannen kurz
nach sonnenaufgang sein pferd hongbo die
nacht verbringt das jeweils in der herde
tagsüber sicher des pfands
zusatzeinkünfte
am bau das heißt rotes baby ist ganz
stolz und gleichzeitig auch sein
einziger besitzt als angestellte der
pferdefarm bekommt er einen raum zum
schlafen und wohnen plus eine spärliche
küche sowie ein bescheidenes
grundeinkommen zum leben reicht es
jedoch nicht die nudeln die seine frau
zum frühstück serviert schmecken gut ein
kleiner trost in der schwierigen
finanziellen situation der familien
ich verdiene im moment gerade knapp
genug um eine familie zu ernähren
wir sind hauptsächlich selbst versorgen
wenn es nichts zu ernten gibt wird es
hart für uns dann müssen wir rausgehen
und gelegenheitsjobs suche im sommer
hofft panzern ping auf touristen die zum
reiten auf die abgelegene farm kommen
im unterschied zum dünnen park den wir
früher besucht haben finden nur wenige
touristen hierher
heute hat man glück ein paar aus den
fernen ländern will reiten
was für den bauern selbstverständlich
ist aber kaum zum überleben reicht genau
das suchen hier die gutverdienenden
besucher aus chinas fernen
millionenstädten natur frische luft ruhe
[Musik]
wir haben diesen ort ausgewählt weil es
hier so still ist und nicht so überfüllt
wie an anderen touristenorten so können
wir in ruhe die schöne graslandschaft
genießen
man fühlt sich hier viel freier für drei
stunden freiheit bezahlen die zwei
touristen umgerechnet rund 40 franken
pferdeführer panisch zufrieden mit
seinem heutigen verdienst doch die
idylle dieser heilen welt drückt kann
und seine frau wollen nicht auf dem land
alt werden
sie wollen weg von hier ihr
zwölfjähriger sohn lebt unter der woche
schon jetzt im nachbardorf
denn gute schulen gibt es hier nicht
frau und herr pannen träumen von einem
modernen leben in der großstadt
ich lebe hier seit 40 jahren
oder sind es 13
ich habe genug von diesem harten leben
ich habe es mehr als satt ich will weg
hier
ich sehne mich nach einer veränderung
ich will nicht nur eine neue umgebung
sondern auch einen neuen lebensstil
nächstes jahr wieder sein pferd sein
einziges hab und gut verkaufen und sich
auf den weg machen in die stadt in eine
unsichere zukunft
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und wir wir verlassen die region von
schlanke mit dem zug
[Musik]
erfahren sie dort wert sind die
chinesische großstadt lernt schon
[Musik]
während sieben stunden sind wir hier in
der nacht unterwegs dazu ist überfüllt
und so war ist so vollgestopft dass
einige passagiere sogar gezwungen sind
stundenlang zu stehen
[Musik]
zum schlafen kommen wir kaum und auch
wer sich einen sitzplatz reserviert hat
muss sich den erkämpfen und stets
behaupten
[Musik]
am frühen morgen erreichen wir die
dreieinhalb millionen stadt land schon
[Musik]
seit über 2000 jahren estland schuh ein
wichtiger verbindungspunkt der
nördlichen seidenstraße und ein
bedeutender ort zur überquerung des
gelben flusses des zweitlängsten stroms
in china
vom bahnhof gehen wir gleich weiter zum
berühmten imbissstube in der besondere
nudeln mit rindfleisch serviert werden
zum frühstück versteht sich
viele chinesen genießen das morgenessen
in diesem restaurant es schmeckt ihnen
ist nährstoffreich und schnell
zubereitet und bild
lange handgefertigte nudeln wie sie
schon vor 400 jahren im chinesischen
chengdu das team stets frisch zubereitet
worden sind
[Musik]
überall entlang der seidenstraße haben
sich teigwaren als nahrungsmittel
verbreitet
hier lerne ich am tisch die lehrerin
jerry hall und ihre tochter die 16
jährige schülerin martin ruhe kennen die
wir einen vormittag lang begleiten
werden
die berühmten und scharf gewürzten dann
schuler nudeln genieße ich vorsichtig
andrew ist eine gute schülerin trotzdem
büffelt sie während ihrer sommerferien
an einer privatschule um in drei jahren
das berüchtigte gau zu bestehen
die übertritts prüfung zur hochschule
freizeit gibt es kaum dass schüler leben
ist ganz auf den künftigen berufs erfolg
ausgerichtet
dieses der empfangsraum der renommierten
internationalen new oriental school die
eltern wenn sie es vermögen lassen sich
das intensive lerntraining für ihre
kinder was kosten
nein das sind keine popstars sondern die
jungen engagierten lehrer dieser schule
in den schulräumen werden wir mit einer
art gegenwelt zu unserer
westeuropäischen wohlfühlgesellschaft
konfrontieren
die schüler haben nur ein ziel auf das
alle hinarbeiten dass gauck die
maturaprüfung zu bestehen den sprung an
die uni zu schaffen
china hat wohl das härteste schulsystem
der welt für viele auch für cernko
beginnt der schulalltag morgens um halb
acht und endet abends um elf mitsamt
hausaufgaben und nachhilfe unterricht
[Musik]
was denn ist sharon russ lebenstraum
hängt wirklich alles von der schule ab
ich möchte andere länder und kulturen
kennenlernen
es gibt dinge die wichtiger sind als das
was man in der schule lernt der
konkurrenzkampf ist hart die zukunft
gehört in china den fleißigen doch der
preis ist hoch
wegen des stresses brauchen immer mehr
chinesische studenten psychologische
hilfe sowie eine klassenkameradin von
cheyrou sie selbst hat glücklicherweise
eltern die sie nicht unter
erwartungsdruck setzten ihr eine
seltenheit
beim lernen haben wir großen druck der
druck lehrt uns aber auch nicht
aufzugeben das ist ebenfalls wichtig im
leben manchmal ist es sehr schwierig
aber es hilft uns unsere träume zu
erreichen
nach der englische stunde laden unruhe
und ihre mutter zu sich nach hause
dort ist auch die großmutter eine
muslimische chinesen zu besuch
als mutter versucht johann ihrer tochter
freiräume und auch zeit zum entspannen
zu geben und als lehrerin spricht die
hoffnung über die mängel des
chinesischen bildungssystems für mich
ist die große prüfung nicht das
wichtigste im leben
sie verursacht so viel stress die
kindheit und viel potenzial gehen
verloren
die schüler verbessern zwar ihr big
wissen aber andere talente und die
sozialkompetenz werden nicht entwickelt
doch dieser harte prüfung können sie an
die uni aber auch dort lernen sie nicht
für das wirkliche leben
die herzliche begegnung aber auch die
leistungsbereitschaft von jamrud haben
mich beeindruckt
die folgen des chinesischen leistungs
willens das steht für mich außer frage
werden wir im westen doch sehr viel
stärker zu spüren bekommen
wir starten zu unserer letzten reise
etappe von der stadt land in die
einstige kaiserstadt skiern
[Musik]
bekam die ski an für seine mächtige
stadtmauer und für die riesigen
grünanlagen
wie es in dem sogenannten revolution
spark trotz des strömenden regens
treffen wir hier auf interessante
anzeigen und auf viele ältere menschen
bei uns kaum vorstellbar eltern
montieren am park bäumen selbst
gebastelte annoncen in denen sie für
ihren sohn eine passende lebenspartnerin
suchen
wegen der ein-kind-politik und den
zahlreichen abtreibungen von denen vor
allem weibliche föten betroffen sind
leidet china unter einem enormen
frauenmangel die rede ist von rund 30
millionen fr
ein schüchterner sohn kommt nicht selbst
aus angst vor gesichtsverlust diese
worte preis seinen angeblich
vielbeschäftigten sohn gleich selbst
dann und hinterfragt ansprüche der
jüngeren generation
heute verlangen die jungen leute sehr
viel
[Musik]
sie haben ganz genaue vorstellungen
puncto alter aussehen größe ausbildung
beruf einkommen wohnort mit solchen
ansprüchen ist es natürlich sehr
schwierig eine wirklich passende
partnerin zu finden
[Musik]
dann treffe ich mit unserer chinesisch
dolmetscherin eine frau und einen mann
die zu geben für sich selbst nach einer
partnerschaft ausschau zu halten
die beiden scheinen sich auch
sympathisch zu sein doch das eis unter
chinesen schmilzt weniger schnell als
bei uns wenn sie diese frau mögen dann
sagen sie es ihr doch einfach und wie
gefällt ihnen dieser mann sieht
glücklich über dieses treffen
jaja sieht sehr sympathisch aus
wollen sie sich nicht mal unverbindlich
treffen einfach zu einer tasse tee oder
so ich habe eine dünne haut
ich habe angst den ersten schritt zu
machen
und der zweite schritt ist noch viel
schwieriger eine etwas ungelenken
bemühungen als partnervermittler haben
nicht sofort gefruchtet aber vielleicht
springt bei den beiden an einem anderen
sonntag doch noch der funke über
[Musik]
bei wem der funke richtig übergesprungen
ist der geht den einst der unzähligen
farina typischen hochzeitsfoto studios
die jungen chinesen sind bemüht sich
stets im allerbesten licht zu zeigen
liu und ghana werden für ihre fotoserie
zwei ganze monatsgehälter hinblättern
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich erkenne mich kaum aber es gefällt
mir
warum gibt ein junges paar so viel geld
aus für ein fotoshooting
weil es ein besonderer tag für
erinnerungen ist in china heiratet man
nur einmal im ganzen leben
das sprichwort sagt wir bekommen
gemeinsam weiße haare und ich werde
immer nett sein zu meiner frau
vielleicht machen wir in ein paar jahren
nochmals solche fotos
[Musik]
kann ich hier schuhe ohne absatz tragen
ohne absatz keine pose
[Musik]
yu na haben sich bei der arbeit
kennengelernt
was denkt nach über eltern welche im
park für sich söhne eine partnerin
suchen wenn man den partner selbst
findet ist das schön
doch wenn man in einem bestimmten alter
niemanden gefunden hat sind solche blind
dates wie im park auch gut
jede person hat ihre eigene situation
wir haben ein sprichwort eine familie
passt zur anderen familie nicht nur
meine persönliche liebe ist wichtig auch
die beiden familien müssen sich melden
[Musik]
hier sind wir am eingang zur grabanlage
des ersten chinesischen kaisers qin shi
huangdi die weltberühmte terrakotta
armee bei fian gehört zu den
allerwichtigsten sehenswürdigkeiten
chinas
vor über 2200 jahren schuf sich der
kaiser eine ganze streitmacht aus ton
die ihm nach seinem tod schutz vor
allfälligen feinden aus dem jenseits
gewähren sollte
jede einzelne figur ist individuell
gestaltet
anblick und anzahl sind überwältigend
7000 soldaten 600 erbe zahlreiche kriegs
wagen und bronze waffen
die stadt schirm bietet ein weiteres
highlight professor keiichi begleitet
mich zum denkmal das an den begründer
erst seitenstraße erinnert
an den chinesischen kaiser haben wo die
aus dem zweiten jahrhundert vor christus
der bedrängte kaiser schickte 138 vor
christus denn entdecke und gesamten
schon los richtung westen bis ins
heutige tadschikistan 126 gesang jan
zurück mit kontakten und informationen
über noch weiter entfernung der hoch
entwickelte zivilisationen
so entstanden unter dem visionären hahn
wo die handelsbeziehungen zwischen china
und zentralasien die bis in den nahen
osten und schließlich bis nach rom
reichten
in china gibt es immer eine
allumfassende absicht die seidenstraße
sollte vier ziele erfüllen neue
wirtschafts korridore für den
warentransport neue politische kontakte
kulturellen austausch und die
selbstentwicklung denn um innerlich zu
wachsen muss der mensch äußerlich die
welt erkunden
auch philosophien und religionen
verbreiteten sich über die seidenstraße
kaiser hamoudi hob seinerzeit den
konfuzianismus zur chinesischen
staatsphilosophie erzählt professor bei
und in seiner zeit kamen die ersten
buddhistischen mönche nach china
was sind die wichtigsten geistigen
errungenschaften der seidenstraße die
freiheit frei zu denken
freiheit bedeutet ein inneres und
äußeres ziel erreichen hemmung
beseitigen barrieren öffnen ohne die
kommunikation mit anderen kulturen gebe
es keinen globalen geist keine
gedankenfreiheit nur dunkelheit die
seidenstraße hat den menschen den
horizont erweitert die seidenstraße sei
so etwas wie die motor der
globalisierung mein professor die bei
uns am abschließenden rundgang über den
markt von sternen die freundlichen
parkbesucher reichen wir einen wasser
pinsel und ich lasse dabei innerlich
unsere reise revue passieren
bei unseren begegnungen in südeuropa in
der türkei im kaukasus und zentralasien
und hier in china habe ich stets gespürt
wie verschieden die welten sind wie hier
die menschen dinge oft unterschiedlichen
finden
dem äußerst wichtigen austausch auf den
roten der seidenstraße verdanken wir
dass wir uns in diesen verschiedenen
kulturkreisen trotzdem nicht ganz fremd
sind
wir haben gelernt aufeinander zuzugehen
und uns besser zu verstehen
und dies ist vielleicht das bewegendste
was mir zum abschluss unserer
wundervollen reise in großer dankbarkeit
zu sagen
[Musik]